[Music]
we all have our favorite Disney
characters but wait until you see some
of your faves reimagined as kids get
ready for this
try not to aw challenge don't forget to
hit that notification valve to never
miss another video and be sure to check
out our community section for even more
fun now let's check out 20 Disney
characters reimagined as kids Elsa
nope sorry we won't let it go frozen is
just one of those movies that's so
iconic we'll be singing these songs
forever and ever but what's even more
iconic is this kid version of Elsa
reimagined by pika Diana on deviantART
look at those adorable blue eyes of
course the original outside would be too
scared to even come outside
but this Elsa looks pretty much fearless
and we're totally digging that dress
it's so cute not to mention that this
Elsa pretty much has her powers under
control or at least that's what it looks
like
either way totally adorable Pocahontas
let's be honest Disney Princesses are
the cutest when we see them as babies
that we rarely get to see them as babies
so as a special treat here's baby
Pocahontas and she's absolutely adorable
she is designed by Davis Kingdom on
deviantART how cute we're totally loving
that little dress and her long hair
seriously she's so cute doesn't she
remind you of lilo just a little bit
either way there are two words that can
describe this totally adorable but wait
we have 18 more Disney characters to go
through and things will get even cuter
than this beast no seriously wait until
you see this the original version of
beast might seem slightly scary even
though we all know the real beauty lies
on the inside but check out the baby
beast who's just totally adorable this
image belongs to Taurus or from
deviantART who did an amazing job even
with a grumpy face he doesn't look that
frumpy does he but we love that the
artist kept beasts original outfit which
makes him look that much cuter now just
imagine a baby Belle standing next to
him seriously
this is so cute we can't get enough
Lattin look at this photo isn't it cute
what didn't you think this Aladdin is
much better than the original Aladdin
we're just kidding nothing can beat the
original Aladdin but this is pretty
adorable this image belongs to Livia
Squinkie from deviantART who really did
a good job at turning aladdin into the
cutest and chubbiest cartoon kid ever
look how absolutely adorable he is when
he stares at his tummy
don't worry Aladdin you won't have this
problem when you're older just imagine a
baby jasmine next to him along with an
extra small version of the flying carpet
we need a baby Aladdin movie.tarzan we
don't spend enough time talking about
Tarzan on this channel so here's his few
seconds of fame or better get his baby
versions few seconds of fame this
beautiful drawing was created by art man
7:39 one and it shows Tarzan in cartoon
style motion pretty cool right Tarzan's
so wild we'd love to see more of his
adventures who knows maybe they'll bring
him back and turn him into another
live-action movie bonus points if we get
to see baby Tarzan but either way this
drawing is absolutely incredible we
really need to give Tarzan more credit
don't be Ursula let's spend a while
talking about villains let's be honest
Disney wouldn't be the same without it's
beautifully flawed villains we just
can't help but love and Ursula is one of
them
check out this fantastic illustration
created by the talented Vivian du Bois
Vivian really did an amazing job it's
showing Ursula in her baby form we
totally buy that this is how Ursula
would have actually looked like and
although she's a villain who gets to do
horrible things later on baby
Ursula is the absolute cutest look at
her cute little octopus outfit and her
awesome hair we just can't get enough
Cruella de Vil Vivian also created this
incredible illustration of one of our
favorite villains ever of course it's
the one and only Cruella de Vil how can
you not love her admittedly we were
pretty scared of her as kids but she's
kind of fabulous isn't she it turns out
her baby version is just as fabulous
check out that coke sure it's slightly
too vague and she's totally lost in it
but that's Karelas style isn't it keep
her awesome hair - it gets even funnier
when you realize
that she's actually painting those dots
on which probably means that this coat
is totally fake good because we don't
want baby Cruella to be cruel anyway
fairy godmother enough about villains
for a while you know who definitely
doesn't get enough credit the fairy
godmother after all without her where
would Cinderella be right now probably
still stuck in that house with her
stepmother
Vivian Dubois reimagined what the fairy
godmother would look like as a baby and
this is just too cute for words
check out the adorable white hair and of
course who could possibly overlook her
outfit she's totally ready to do some
serious magic with her wand
who knows maybe she's turning a pumpkin
into a carriage for practice Donald and
Nikki even though this channel focuses a
lot on Disney Princesses we can't forget
about the oh jeez Disney wouldn't be the
same without Donald and Mickey and here
they are reimagined as kids this image
belongs to cute little animals on
deviantART and it is in fact insanely
adorable just look at them that neither
of them knew they'd become iconic
characters that would change the cartoon
world forever
Donald doesn't look happy that Mickey's
trying to take his fall does he either
way this is the most adorable thing
we've ever seen sorry if we keep on
repeating ourselves but all of these
artists really know how to bring the
cute out of Disney Aereo oh look its
baby re oh no not the famous teen
sensation the actual baby Ariel as in
The Little Mermaid
this image belongs to Joel 128 from
deviant art and we're absolutely in love
with it her hair is still fabulous but
we definitely clocked that bib with
Triton's Trident as the logo adorable
she already looks like she's up to no
good but that pacifier definitely adds
the cute factor
seriously though she totally looks like
she's hiding something we bet that baby
Ariel would still get in a lot of
trouble on a regular basis dr. Vasily a
doctor phacelia is a sly and evil as you
can get and plenty of us were totally
scared of him as children and we still
kind of are let's be honest he's just
pure evil so to make sure you're not
scared of dr. phacelia anymore here's a
baby version of this glorious villain
this photo is created by a deviant art
artist called Eleonora
who did a pretty awesome job at showing
a kid version of dr. Vasily a sure he
still has a mischievous look on his face
but you have to admit he looks way less
evil than his original version check out
that impressive necklace with actual
fangs that's definitely something he'd
wear even as a kid snow white and who
can possibly forget about one of the
most iconic Disney Princesses there is
snow white is often overlooked because
she's so old but truth be told she is
completely epic but what's even more
epic this chibi version of Snow White
created by Rizzo V monster from
deviantART she looks so happy cuddling
that bird as Snow White actually would
we love the iconic hair and of course
her red hair bow lover hater let's be
honest Disney would not be the same
without snow right and we'd never get
this adorable chibi version either
here's a question if Snow White is this
small how small are the dwarves we just
hope the TV version stays away from red
apples because there's no need for that
is there Captain Jack Sparrow let's step
away from cartoon characters and check
out Howard Disney pirates are doing we
don't talk much about the Pirates of the
Caribbean on this channel so we wanted
to make sure we get our dose of Captain
Jack Sparrow this image belongs to
Camilla from deviantART who did an
amazing job at showing our favorite
pirate in a chibi form Captain Jack is
considered to be somewhat scary but this
version definitely isn't we're totally
in love with his outfit and his hair
well his entire look is pretty much
awesome seriously even though pirates
aren't supposed to be cute this is
amazing crew you know who's an
underrated Disney character grew not
enough is being said about this villain
turned softie after he decides to adopt
three adorable orphan girls but check
out GRU and true as little babies this
image belongs to yo cute artists from
deviantART and it's absolutely fantastic
gross totally being his weird and
awkward self but hey he's just letting
it out of his system
we love that hair curl at the top of his
head although his toys make us raise her
eyebrows and we totally have a few
questions for this artist we're also
completely in love with this image
Sulley and we're down to our top six
cutest Disney characters we imagined as
kids
seriously you're not ready for this
we're starting with a one and only Sully
although he's considered a monster
Sully's already not that bad
but wait until you see his baby version
this one was designed by 11 Odyssey from
deviantART and it's honestly fantastic
he looks like a plush toy boo would
probably keep in her room as a memory of
Sully or maybe this was her actual toy
and this is why she was never afraid of
him to begin with either way he's
absolutely adorable and we're totally
here for it
Merida you know we had to include one of
our favorite Disney Princesses who
doesn't love Merida she totally goes
against all stereotypical Disney
princess standards and does her own
thing and so does the baby Merida
designed by Irene martini from
deviantART she looks so cute her hair is
of course absolutely adorable and were
totally in love with that green dress
but just look at how she's squeezing
that there cuteness overload seriously
we can't get over that hair she really
does have hands-down the best Disney
Princess hair ever Tiana
if you watch our videos you also know we
have a soft spot for Tiana when it comes
to favorite Disney Princesses she's one
of the most underrated princesses ever
but probably the most independent one
maybe Tiana was reimagined by Kia IVA
from deviantART and we're absolutely in
love with it
check her out we love that crown and
interests and it looks like she's
definitely ready to run her own
restaurant even as a baby she really is
one of the most hardworking and focused
Disney Princesses ever but if you want
to know other reasons why she's our
favorite you'll have to watch some of
our other videos goofy we showed you
Donald Duck and Mickey so you know we
have to put goofy in the mix goofy is
definitely an underrated character that
deserves more credit for being Weld
goofy he's absolutely hilarious we
managed to find this adorable baby goofy
image and honestly we're totally in love
just look how tiny and cute he is
sometimes we forget that Goofy's
actually a dog considering he can stand
on two legs but other Disney dogs can't
talk about being a superior Disney
character that really does deserve more
credit Melana
are you ready for this cuteness
seriously are you ready baby Moana is
already cute but this image is the
cutest thing we've ever seen it's baby
Moana with the one and only hey hey
this illustration belongs to master art
from deviantART and honestly it really
is adorable
just look at her big eyes and an
adorable hair and although hey hey as a
comic relief to any situation it's
actually really cute seeing them
together like this after all he played
an important part in this story whether
he liked it or not are you ready for the
very final Disney character reimagined
as a kid here it is
Maleficent it's Maleficent we're so
obsessed with the descendants you know
we had to add in the one and only queen
of everything that is evil no one does
it quite like Maleficent and no one does
it quite like Ringo Yan from deviantART
who reimagined Maleficent as a child
just look how cute sure she might have
green skin and she might look like she's
doing some serious business but oh my
goodness this is so cute she could turn
us into frogs and we still just awed her
look let's be honest Maleficent wins
this entire thing the end and that's it
for our video thank you so much for
watching
see you next time
[Music]